Shawn is with us in New Orleans hi Shawn
how are you Dave I am fantastic I have
to tell you it is such an honor to speak
to you but thank you so much for taking
the call my pleasure
how can I help I talk to talk understand
have read the books have attended the
FPU classes have facilitated FP classes
wife and I have gotten out of debt
except for the house before and then
stupid is as stupid does I've got all
the tools in the toolbox college use
that hammer backwards every now and then
and we find ourselves willingly and
through our own volition back in a
little bit of debt not too much we've
got about $28,000 mainly in a vehicle
also a lawn mower we bought have a plan
to attack this and get this knocked out
between the next 8 to 12 months
depending on a decision that I think
you're going to hopefully clarify for me
with sinking funds its what kind of got
us trouble the first time Wow what is
the role of sinking funds when we're in
that baby step two and three it's like
things on the horizon like braces high
school tuition these are things I know
we're coming up but I'm not
incorporating them into my monthly
budget because I'm trying to attack my
debt so it kind of just pops up on me
like surprise surprise here I've been
the whole time which then causes us to
make poor decisions
so you've led Financial Peace University
twice and you don't know how to put
blame upcoming races into your budget
I've let it once and the braces are a
new problem and I understand it's kind
of upcoming expense you put it into the
budget and Christmas is going to be in
December this year it is so yes the
Christmas you know vacations we have
that incorporated into our thinking
plans but just any other thing just the
routine stuff it's like once we're out
of debt we find ourselves a but now
we're getting ready to start attacking
our you know fully funded emergency fund
and then start to work on our retirement
savings which we have not stopped but
your monthly budget has to incorporate
annual expenses everything whatever your
annual expenses are got and you have to
build that in
but that didn't cause you to buy a
lawnmower no not at all
absolutely look I own it and hopefully
we were joking online just now on the
YouTube page about hopefully you don't
call the wambulance on me how much you
owe on your lawnmower 4500 I bought it
three months ago we just we just moved
out we purchased built a home on five
acres and purchased a lawn mower have
plans to have it paid off in the next
again next six dead six to ten months
with the vehicle that we purchased and a
lawn mower it's it's not smart Dave if
it were smart I would have it would be
the showing show I guess I realize that
I just I don't understand I mean I think
you've got you're gonna have to reach a
different level of conviction not just
shame oh and I think that's where we are
and when we are here now we are sick and
tired of being sick and tired and doing
the things that we know aren't wise and
just it's it has reached the point and
we're there we are fired up and ready
and they have that gazelle intensity
that we have when we first started out
but I don't know if it's just just again
the wambulance but it's just time just
eats up hatching you're like what am I
doing this for it's such a long race and
it is and I know it needs to be to be
successful and we are both at that point
now and ready to do we need to do what
do you make a year too much about 140
combined for the household okay and and
I have on a monthly basis we have right
now for our snowball about some 300
compost I'm just intrigued um so where
you just do you feel like you were just
emotionally lazy yeah you know I think
you know what it is is I think that she
works so hard and you sacrifice and I
think it's a badge of honor and it's in
its but you're doing all along no no no
no okay I'm saying I mean walk in Home
Depot and go five grand in debt on a
lawnmower I just that's just got to be
emotional laziness and that's what I
mean about commitment I'm not picking on
your shaming you you're doing enough of
that of yourself but
I'm you man I really want to get down
inside this and fix that because you got
to you got to put that back together and
go that never never never